not all problems not all choices not all
decisions are made equal and I want you
to go back through look through your
list of examples and you can see some
are clearly are easier more
straightforward more direct more clear
to decide than others right and the way
that we classify these is by saying they
sit on a continuum that we say one end
is what we call structured okay there
you go one then and the other side
because it's the opposite
it's called unstructured okay now the
idea is that all decisions or choices or
problems about which a decision has to
be made
they sit somewhere on this continuum
okay now we more towards one end more
towards the other it's very very very
unusual for something to be completely
one or completely the other so in the
middle you've got sort of semi
structured it's kind of like an
in-between right but problems will
definitely lean one way or the other
so even though you might not necessarily
be exactly here or exactly there these
are still very useful categories to
think in terms of okay so what do I mean
well let's consider a problem like say
the weather okay so I'm gonna do is
think about some examples which draw out
properties of different kinds of
problems structured or unstructured okay
so I said the weather now do you think
this is an easy or a hard thing to
predict easy or hard is it a
straightforward or is it a difficult
problem to solve if you were trying to
predict the weather how easy would it be
to make a decision based on this okay
now I think it's basically a hard
decision okay it's not easy to make this
decision you need a lot of information
there's a lot of computational power to
do it the reason why I can think or at
least two reasons okay number one okay
weather is very chaotic
right it's unpredictable okay all kinds
of crazy things sort of happen things
which even though we have all this great
knowledge you know for instance if
there's a really really bad tornado or
tsunami or hurricane or something like
that how much notice do we have
generally you know know like well what
kind of time scale we're talking about
do we know weeks in advance not
generally not generally even if it's
like biggest ones in history okay do you
know what minutes in advance you
probably know by then right at least so
somewhere in between there okay
so where I'd probably say maybe a few
days or something like that okay they're
like next week this thing's gonna hit
you can see it's on the coasts for me
and then it's gonna come onto land so
even though there are these really large
events they hard to pretty big hairy
okay so there's this is a problem this
is a quality of an unstructured problem
this one okay number one it's chaotic if
the situation you're looking at is hard
to predict okay so obviously the flip
side of that for something to be
structured means it is very predictable
always the same thing every single time
okay now what else well let's think
about a question a decision like say I
think it was Polk who suggested one of
the decisions you have to make maybe on
an annual basis is I have to get
presents for people okay presents you
have to buy gifts for people okay so
let's just narrow it down a little bit
where there was one example suppose you
determined you want to get someone music
okay you want to buy someone an album or
song or a bunch of songs okay how do you
choose that you choose how do you come
up with the decision of what's the arm
what's the best album for instance
what's the best album for person X right
then you're trying to buy music for how
do you come up with a decision like that
how you come with the inside yes ah
good all right so hold on number one if
they're if they're really devoted to
like a particular band or something like
that okay
then it's not safe you can just get
anything from this band and it doesn't
matter if it's terrible or not don't
like it okay but then you know what if
it's not what if they don't have any
particular band that they are like
totally devoted to what kinds of
decisions what kind of factors would
affect your decision or not so there's
simple ones I'm trying to make a choice
between all of these different ones
right now things like say genre
okay right having things like say length
or features or maybe even within a John
ru life particular songs and not others
okay now do you see what's the problem
this is not a chaotic situation okay but
well what makes it hard to decide here
what's the what's the what's the problem
you what's the challenge why is music a
hard decision to pick out good everyone
has different tastes there's a word for
that right we ever wanted one word for
that which is that this kind of problem
is subjective subjective okay so it's
like everyone sort of has their own
opinion okay what if you were trying to
put a score on for instance an early a
piece of art okay and you get five
different people you'll get five
different scores okay so everyone
disagrees it's subjective this is a
difficult choice to make obviously the
opposite of that is objective okay if
it's like well the thing that makes the
song good is that it's long right just
the length of a song that's the that's
the only property that's informative at
all right well that's very objective
everyone can agree all such-and-such a
song as three minutes and 53 seconds so
that's something everyone has to agree
upon right but good music is it's not
about just something as simple and
objective is that right okay you also
have things like say I'm going to come
over to this side now when you've got a
structured problem if you've got a
problem which can be sold
mathematically okay
or another way of saying it is
algorithmically with an algorithm okay
if something can be solved just by maths
that's really easy okay so for instance
if I have a question okay
I do your body type right are you heavy
or light or you know you underweight or
overweight all right in the middle or so
above or below okay now in terms of
judging that there's a mathematical way
to determine that right we give it a
name actually given that clue what do we
use we use the boss body mass index
right BMI okay so what is the VMO it's
like weight over height squared right
now can you see all of those things I'll
just wait in height right there
objective okay
everyone can agree you know on how many
kilos and how many centimeters right how
many meters and then you just pop it
into a formula okay and so that'll give
you a decision very easily as to whether
someone is underweight overweight you
know obsessed and obese that kind of
thing so what would be the opposite of
this what's the opposite of a problem
which you can solve like mathematically
it's sort of abstract that's not a bad
word okay you might say it's qualitative
as opposed to quantitative okay again
I'm looking at say the art piece right
there's no I can't put that into a
formula and it'll automatically tell me
ah what's the best kind of you know
painting or something like that okay
okay so what have I got here one more
one more phrase to put on each okay
this sort of gets at why it's called
structured or unstructured okay we call
structured problems well-defined
ill-defined is the idea if you have a
situation and this is sort of like with
the weather right and you know lots of
information about it okay it's
well-defined then that helps you to make
decisions about it if you know lots of
things okay but if it's ill-defined if
it's like you have to make a choice but
you there's lots of things you don't
know okay there's lots of things that
you can't know about the situation okay
then that's hot okay do you guys
remember did I show you the video about
the the Martian rover Curiosity right
that was landing on to the surface of
Mars and there were all of these
unknowns in the situation that made the
problem very hard to solve right for
instance we can't we can't actually
manually control you know its descent
into the atmosphere because it's too far
away right we can't send signals so what
was information about where it's
entering what speed it's going what
direction it's pointing etc etc those
things are hard to know right in advance
so that's an ill-defined problem okay
and when you take all of these together
can you see how you've got structured
and unstructured right in some senses
you could say the way to make a decision
about this kind of problem is very
well-defined structure to it okay you
can know exactly what steps you go
through can come with a decision as
opposed to over here or it's like I
don't even know where to start
how do I make a decision and how do I
know if it's the right decision so let
me give you an example and
try and think about this okay let's come
on that I'll give you a couple of
examples let's think about marking exams
okay
now you guys don't have to do much
marking lucky you okay but you can still
get your head your mind into the head of
marker is marking an exam a structured
problem or is it an instruction problem
what do you think okay all right now so
so the first answer is it depends right
if it's multiple choice it's way over
this side isn't it okay very variable to
find you know exactly what the things
are it's very objective it's right or
it's wrong yes okay good so this
multiple choice what about other kinds
of problems Oh cuz not everything is
multi choice right where else would you
categorize these okay so we said we said
Matt obviously you can have Matt's it's
multiple choice right but other kinds of
stuff like an extended response question
right if it's worth three marks okay
people would disagree on where the three
marks should go or what something is
worth do you see there's some
subjectivity
there's trying to creep in okay and then
you can creep even further over this
side okay not all the way but say
something like I would say art or music
okay yeah it's it's hard to say where
exactly they go because you know partly
because I don't have much of an artistic
eye I don't know what the qualities are
there are people measure right cuz you
know when I look at what was that chord
it was called blue poles or something do
you guys hear about it was just a
painting was a canvas that was covered
in blue paint that's it and apparently
was a massive hit it got until like the
contemporary Museum of Contemporary Art
no look at me so I don't know what those
qualities are okay but some people do so
it's down this end but it's not all the
way on something like people can still
say this is good and this is bad art
okay but it still leaves in this
direction okay